what's up guys so as you guys probably
already know there was this crazy trend
for RGB and tempered glass during 2017
the Corsair crystal series was at the
forefront of this movement and the 570 X
was a more premium version of the two
options available from Corsair crystal
series it's tempered glass panel on the
sides front and top combined with this
included RGB fans make it a beautiful
showcase and no one passing by your room
would ever miss noisy it's definitely a
premium top-of-the-line case but is it
functionally that it provides on par
with asking price up $108 well today I'm
going to be taking an in-depth look at
this gorgeous case and at the end hope
to provide you guys with enough
information so you guys can make an
educated decision so let's jump right in
of course your 570 X is a mid tower ATX
case design with RGB and tempered glass
in mind the case comes with three of
course there's SP 120 RGB fans if you
guys are interested in how those fans
perform make sure to check out my
overview of them by seeing link down in
the description below anyways the case
comes as force dirty glass panels I
don't really like Thea they aren't
tinted any one color they are just clear
glass out of the box they come with
their plastic wrap on the outside to
protect the glass pieces from dirt or
debris I recommend that you guys don't
remove this plastic wraps until you guys
are completely finished with our build
in order to avoid getting your
fingerprints on the glass or smudge it
in between the fans and the glass you
will find a nice magnetic dust filter
that is easy to remove and clean on top
for any radiator fans that you guys may
install and on the front for the three
included case fans the placement of a
dust filter on the outside of the case
makes it easily available without having
to open up the main portion of the case
but you do it happen to remove the
smaller glass panels associated with the
dust filter on top of the case you'll
find the power button
a headphone jack and a mic jack two USB
3.0 ports three buttons to control the
various effects up to RGB fans on the
front you'll find a white illuminated
course your logo and of course the
intake fans okay guys let me go through
all the movies so this first one right
here it's a single color with full sync
fast this one changes to give all the
different colors that it has and it
pulses the next mode is just static and
simple
and this one is slow pulsing in a single
folder and here's a super flash a
super-fast pulsing mode right here
that's all the most you can also change
the speed that you want the pulsing and
other stuff like that like if you want
like super slow or super fast and let me
go through all the different colors
right there
so there's red orange yellow green blue
purple white that's all the colors on
the right side you'll find 2 3.5 inch
hard drive base and two 2.5 SSD drive
bays on this case all of your cables are
showcased so that you guys better be on
your topic game however there is a metal
bar prided for you to assist you hide
your cables the metal bar is a bit small
in my opinion though finally on left
side you'll find the main cavity for
most of your parts here you guys can
mount a 120 or 140 millimeter radiator
on top but it is a tight fit with the
RAM sticks to make sure to keep that in
mind or you guys can utilize some front
fans and set up a push-pull setup like I
did on the back you guys amount a 120
millimeter fan and radiator this case is
very : neutral because the case is all
black and the fans are RGB if you guys
are building a white stuff then maybe
you guys are consider the force your 5
70 X white or red 4 black and red cells
this case does support custom liquid
cooling what it is in the most friendly
port
if you guys have costing liquid cooling
in mind then I recommend that you guys
look for a case build with liquidity
cooling in mind so all those features
are great and nice but there are a few
flaws but courser has listened to our
feedback and has tried to fix the
original mistakes with the new models of
this case for example everyone despise
how there is no routing for the GPU
cables or the front panel connectors but
with the new version of this case
courser has implemented a grommet to
route these cables through also everyone
despise how big of oversight was from
Corsair to not include a cover for the
power supply cables
however courser has added threads which
screws around the edge of power supply
for the new power supply cover covers
that cover only is four dollars on
coursers website that may be worth
checking out those two modifications
solved two biggest flaws of this case
and that only leaves tiny little
imperfections left like incompatibility
of some RAM sticks with the top mounted
radiator now that we got all the facts
out of the way let's talk about the
building experience of this case this PC
was on the first pcs I ever built and it
was really easy but there are some
things that you have to pre-plan when
working with this case for example on a
normal case you may lay the case when
it's right side we're working on left
side however on this case there is a
glass panel on the right side so you
guys have to remember to take it off
before you guys start doing that there
aren't really any other hindering
factors to this case other than the
hindrance created from the presence of
glass on all sides I'm not sure prism
the this case are all cases but I found
it difficult to screw in the screws that
use in this case because the threads
weren't exactly right but other or not I
don't have any major gripes next let's
discuss maintenance of this case since
the dust filters are clearly visible
except for the one underneath their
power supply you had to clean them quite
frequently
recent dust becomes quite evident after
just a few weeks overall this is a
premium case built for premium builders
I would not recommend this case to
people who are on a tight budget phase
this case is not worth sacrificing GPU
level a CPU level getting a water cooler
or even a better motherboard or
switching to an nvme storage this case
is great but should be the last thing
you decide to upgrade after all it is
just a box that holds your parts your
parts are what actually matter so I
recommend you guys get all top of line
PC components first before you guys jump
on to buying this case by this I don't
mean by the new I nine or bigger French
Edition or anything stream like that I
mean you guys just have the top-line
mainstream products such as liquid
cooler and gave me storage and
definitely an i7 name guys are a gamer
maybe a GTX 1080 or 1080i your PC parts
are so much more important than this
case so make sure to keep that in mind
when you guys are considering this case
however if you guys know that I'm I
fires all you need on a GTX 1060 s more
than enough for gaming needs then this
may be worth considering but this is a
premium case and considering that you
guys are interested in this case I
assume that you guys want the best
products and as a result you guys should
probably get the best parts for your PC
before jumping onto this case otherwise
you guys should get other cases which
are cheaper overall this case is an
awesome showcase for your bills but it
doesn't actually add any tangible value
to your ability if you guys really want
this case and I already have a premium
build but this would barely push you
over your budget then you guys should
just buy it because I know that you guys
won't be happy with anything else for
all you guys who are just considering
this case but I don't crave it then I
recommend that you guys to buy something
else and just save your money and maybe
by a few came for something and all of
you guys who are would sacrifice your PC
parts for this case don't just don't do
it it's not worth it
this is an awesome case meant for people
who don't have a budget and want the
most premium case while this case is an
extreme as some $100 pieces or even the
coarser slate this is more than enough
for your RGB paving and will serve you
well ultimately this is a great case
that I recommend to people who don't
have to sacrifice PC part supported well
guys that's all I have for you today if
you guys are interested in their
unboxing of this case then make sure to
check out my quick unboxing and
description below of this case if you
guys liked this video make sure to give
it a like and these guys loved it and
we'd like to see more just like this
then make sure to subscribe and turn on
that bail notification I would love to
hear thoughts about this case so make
sure you guys comment on what you guys
are thinking I hope you guys enjoyed
this video and until next time bye